let's see if we can talk to a couple
more people here let's go let's go to
the six eight one area code why don't we
try six eight one go ahead 81 uh hello
yes that's you oh well just give me one
sec Wow
I didn't think I'd actually get to talk
take your time what are you doing for
the weekend we're just doing a shelf
just want to say man huge fan
thank you huge fan I love what you're
doing man appreciate it where are you
from I really think I'm from West
Virginia oh okay I thought so
yeah pretty red state here parents are
red I'm not necessarily blue but okay I
certainly lean more that to that side
but cool man I wanted to ask you a
question because I feel like your your
stance on things and the way that you
talk about things are pretty pretty fair
thank you and whenever I talk to people
around here it's pretty biased honestly
yeah West Virginia is not the most I'll
say intellectual state but uh yeah with
the whole issue on gun control and
things right now yep I really only have
a few people I can talk to about it and
I was wondering what is the actual
argument for keeping assault-style
rifles in stores and able to be bought
by the American people is the actual
argument that we need them to stand up
to a tyrannical government well there's
a few different argument depends when
you talk to you right so there are those
who are just Second Amendment
absolutists who say listen there's no
reason that we would remove the assault
style rifles so thus they stay in other
words it's just it's a right there's
nothing these are legal guns we've got a
Second Amendment that's it now those
same people would probably say yeah but
I don't want Dick's Sporting Goods
selling shoulder-mounted RPGs which
immediately means they concede there is
sideline it's just a matter of where you
draw the line so that's one group of
people there's another group of people
who will say you
can't define what an assault-style rifle
is and they're putting memes online
where there's like four guns and they
say identify the assault-style rifle and
like if you can't they say see because
you couldn't identify which is the
assault rifle or whatever therefore they
should all be sold in stores and then
yes you also do have the tyrannical
government types who believe that I
guess if the government became
tyrannical with their Apache helicopters
and their Abrams tanks and nuclear
weapons and all that right that if you
had an ar-15 you you would be fine like
that so I mean you know there's a lot of
different arguments that that people put
forward and some of them overlap some of
them don't I just have a feeling that
that they're gonna start falling away
and we're going to come to like some
front that is going to be the
constitutional enlist like you were
saying or or it's going to be the people
saying we need them for for the people
and our well-regulated militias that we
keep up so well yeah I just don't know
where the front is gonna be on because I
feel like the tyrannical government side
we need them for the tyrannical
government side that could be a hostile
side yes and good was the know exactly
exactly where it's gonna be it might be
in a different place in West Virginia
than in some other parts of the country
some of these issues might come down to
States ultimately but I think it's a
it's a very prescient conversation
that's going on right now and I
appreciate you calling in and and asking
about it always good to hear from people
from West Virginia